this is Dylan and this is Cole I'm Dylan
I'm Cole I'm Dylan
the twins meteoric rise to fame all
started before they could even talk well
we are pretty much born into it really
in 1993 E.T was there as they made their
small screen debut in Grace Under Fire
get to look right away
before hitting the big screen in Big
Daddy six years later
you like hockey like hockey this is a
big important game
cut the crap cut the crap are you guys
ready for all the the media attention
you're gonna get you guys are big stars
now yes sir yes sir what do you think
about that awesome how's it working with
Adam Sandler
[Music]
they had some crazy you know thing out
in the papers and all the agents were
bringing kids in and I think they were
the first ones we saw and they just uh
and it's pretty damn they're pretty damn
cool those kids you'll find the exact
something to make you personally laugh
it's it's awesome it's it's like it's
like a little pinpoint your personality
and find out like that it's like you
could be a two-year-old and he'll make
you laugh then Cole joins some famous
friends Santa's coming
yes
Santa's coming
and set his sights on his first
on-screen Crush Now what is my first
line
why did we agree okay
I remember being infatuated with
Jennifer Aniston friend sits in this
perfect little bubble of golden
nostalgia
and here's a dose of Disney Nostalgia
you could do anything I can do
yeah
I can't
and better let's not get carried away
at 12 years old Dylan and Cole shop to
stardom with The Suite Life of Zack and
Cody their on-screen Antics reflecting
their real life relationships he almost
shoved my head in the toilet
you almost shook his head hey it's from
other stuff that's what brothers do I
can't deny I wanted to shove his head in
the toilet I mean
the playful pair stepped away from the
spotlight to attend New York University
graduating with honors before carving
their own separate paths while Dylan
returned to films we have got to stop
meeting like this you're right I'll have
restraining orders drafted immediately I
am just a humble actor I read the lines
and I speak the words
Cole settled in as fan favorite Jughead
on Riverdale Mr Dupont I'm going to
fight these accusations tooth and nail I
think I talked to my Disney self as like
uh like a whatever 11 year old he'd be
like no way are people buying this
no way is this working
pair brothers are still living this
sweet life in long-term relationships
Cole is with model Ari Fournier and
Dylan with long time love Barbara Palvin
I think our relationship this is too
much information is stronger than ever
and there's never a shortage of
Brotherly Love I talk to him every day
we still face time every day
for every year of my life
foreign